welcome to the machine learning
unplugged episode two these are shows
where the conversations are much more
off the cuff and we don't do any
preparation in advance well to be honest
it's against my religion not to do any
preparation but relatively speaking we
don't do as much preparation we hope
that this will create a casual yet
dynamic dialogue with a different
stylistic flair than our formal street
talk now i'm tim scarf and we also have
keith duggar and walid subber as
co-interviewers they almost need no
introduction for fans of mlst
keith of course got his phd from mit and
walid is the consummate polymath and is
extremely well known for [ __ ] posting on
linkedin about what he perceives to be
the deep learning runaway train now
today we're going to be bringing
waleed's linguistics now to help us
co-interview our guest so on that
subject dr guy emerson is our guest
today guy is a computational linguist
and obtained his phd from cambridge
university where he's now a research
fellow and lecturer he models human
language implements those models
computationally and then tests them
using real-world data
guy is also an aficionado of ballroom
and latin dancing which we'll let him
get away with um guys it's an absolute
honour to have you on the podcast i was
just reading your phd thesis and your
opening line was that your thesis was
all about meaning how to represent it
how to learn it you said that you wanted
to shed light on what it means to know a
language and to push forward the limits
of machine learning so from a machine
learning point of view a learning
algorithm requires that um you know
requires an objective right so in the
case of language what should that
objective be and you argued that it
should learn semantic representations
that are generally useful rather than
tied to a specific task you argue that
linguistics clarifies the goal and
machine learning provides the tools the
aim of distributional semantics is to
design computational techniques that can
automatically learn the meanings of
words from a body of text the twin
challenges are how do we represent
meaning and how do we learn those
representations
we want to learn the meanings of words
from a corpus exploiting the fact that
the context of a word tells us something
about its meaning this is known as the
distributional hypothesis it's an idea
which you said had its roots in american
structuralism and british lexicology
although we will debate whether the
company of words means statistical
co-occurrence or logical and type
constraints many will know the quote
often cited from firth which is that you
know a word well by the company it keeps
and most work on distributional
semantics learns a vector space model
where the meaning of each word is
represented as a point in a high
dimensional vector space you argued in
your 2018 phd thesis that
vector space models can not capture
various aspects of meaning such as
polysemi which is a greek word meaning
of many senses so for example the word
get might mean understand or procure or
become um anyway it's amazing to have
you on the show guy i mean why don't you
start by saying hello and expanding a
bit on your thesis because you presented
a distributional model which can learn
truth conditional semantics can you tell
us a bit about it
yeah yeah
well the thought actually i could just
follow up on one point that you
mentioned when you said
people usually cite harris and firth
about distribution of semantics
because i think actually most people who
cite them haven't actually read those
papers that they're cited if you go and
read first and i did because i thought i
actually want to know what did he
actually say about about meaning he
spends a long time analyzing poetry
actually which is probably not what
people were thinking of now if you're
training you know a
huge language model they're not thinking
oh can we do a better analysis of uh you
know a particular poet's
um a particular poet's body of work
you know but that's something that that
ferc was interested in
so i think people you know took those
ideas as
inspiration in terms of modern
distributional semantics
in my work what i was trying to do and
what i'm still doing so i'm still
building on that work that i did for my
phd is to have a truth conditional
approach to distributional semantics so
not just learning vectors
um and you know if you really think
about why do we want to learn vectors
for everything and if you look at you
know
modern deep learning you put everything
as a vector right
and there are good computational reasons
for that in terms of vectors being
well defined
you know computationally convenient but
if you really want to model meaning
is a vector the right thing to use
and so
uh in my work i'm trying to look at a
different approach where i would where
we can look at meaning in terms of truth
so we can say when is a word or a
sentence true and what is it true of and
characterize meaning in that way and
then to do it in a distributional way so
rather than trying to sit down and
you know write down a theory by hand
actually learn that theory from data
which is really a big challenge and i
think that's a challenge which more
traditional linguists
um have
not looked at in as much detail i think
sometimes underestimate the difficulty
of actually trying to pin down you know
what meaning really is when you think
about how you can actually learn it from
actual data
and so trying to connect those two sites
together so the the formal truth
conditional aspect of semantics with the
data-driven distributional approach
maybe you could maybe you could talk a
little bit about because i and i'm going
to kind of play devil's advocate here
um you know somebody could say look you
know hey my uh
my numerical vectors are really probably
more appropriately arrays and i love
telling your um
your thesis you spent some time to talk
about that kind of confusing terminology
the difference between vectors and
computer science versus vectors
algebraically et cetera so so kudos to
that but somebody could say hey look
my arrays you know they're just real
numbers um
if if the machine learning algorithm
finds it useful to to work with
probabilities they could easily be
probabilities so in what sense oh i mean
my model is also probabilistic so on
that level i definitely agree that you
know i'm not i'm not getting completely
away from
from using vectors using probabilities
in my work i mean if you look at the
details of the model you know you can
find
vectors right um but the difference is
what is the high level structure of the
model so rather than just saying okay
we've got vectors in vectors out we're
going to
you know
fit the data but then actually what are
we trying to learn so i'm what i'm
trying to do is to have a model where we
have that high level structure which we
can interpret in a linguistic way but
then leave the details to the machine
learning algorithms yeah and that's what
that's what i wanted you to mention
there so so really when you say you know
it's it's about these you know truth or
these um truth conditional functions
what you're saying is that on top of the
normal vectors and i'm going to use that
word you know loosely the way most
people on top of the normal vectors
you're imposing some additional
structure or some additional constraints
namely
the laws of probability theory and some
comp compositional rules for how to go
from
from truth functionals on words to truth
functionals on on higher structures
sentences
phrases etc is that right i'm hesitant
to say truth functional onwards because
um
what i'm not doing is saying that the
input is a sentence and then an output
is you know truth or something else like
that and i think a lot of for example
that if you look at large language
models and that approach to language
everything's in terms of of language
right this you've got words that you've
observed you're predicting the next word
everything's in terms of words
in my work i'm saying that we need to
have this distinction between the words
and the objects that the words are
describing
okay and of course if you think i'm
doing distributional semantic this
immediately seems tricky right because
we don't actually observe the the object
right we just observe words
so in doing distributional semantics it
becomes quite tricky because
the actual entities are all latent you
don't observe those so it becomes a
computational challenge to actually
build a model that you know they can do
that at all
right um
by having that structure
which is you know in it's a very high
level structure in terms of the model
because the details of what actually are
we using to represent an entity how are
we actually representing
um the meaning of a word
the details of that you have to go into
the parameters of the model but the high
level structure
is in terms of this relationship between
words
entities and truth
can i say guy that you are that your
main concern is
that
there aren't so many operations you can
do on vectors
right is that is that really the
inspiration of this that you need a
richer object yeah that's one way you
can put it the vectors don't really have
the kind of structure that we will that
we would want to to talk about lots of
logical concepts and compositional
concepts they just don't
you don't have corresponding
operations in a vector space so for
example
we know in language we need to do
conjunction and negation and all that
stuff yeah while while all i can do with
vectors is similarity i mean the main
while language composition is more
complex that that's the inspiration yeah
right okay yeah but but but uh the
the thesis is still the same in that
words get their meaning from
co-occurrence from data
you you still share that with the
traditional
right well i i would say that
you can't get a hundred percent of the
meaning purely from text you do need to
have some kind of you know grounded
context as well so okay you know a
purely distributional model is not going
to give a complete
semantic model because you you know you
do need to somehow get that connection
to the real world to the word and this
is what this is where truth comes in in
the traditional truth conditional
semantics like
something has a meaning if i really
understand how the word is
if yeah can we can we leave aside
grounding for a little bit because i do
i definitely want to get into grounding
with you a bit later but
i think we can stay within the context
that walid brought up which is
so the distributional learning on text
is it do you still believe that it's the
case that everything that can be learned
from the text so forget about other
grounding material but everything that
can be learned from the text
can be learned by
co-occurrence or
are there even longer range you know or
or or less statistical relationships
that are going to be missed
well i guess it depends a bit on how
you're defining code currents if you
just mean cold currents in a word window
then i would say no that's not going to
be enough because you do have you know
longer distance connections within a
text even within one sentence right you
can have long distance dependencies
within a document you're going to have
you know relationships within the text
that are maybe less formalized but as
you know it's still there
that latter part i'm not i haven't even
begun to put that in my model i'm just
looking you know within one sentence in
terms of what i've actually implemented
in my work but
you know i'm aware of the bigger picture
that even
looking at the you know syntactic and
semantic relations within a sentence is
is not going to be the complete picture
in terms of what you could learn from
text okay
no matter how large the corpus
so when it comes to the size of the text
i think here is is an area where
you can see a difference in um
in research goals between
different researchers so
you know you see these huge language
models being trained now which are
trained on
such enormous corpora that
it's just
it's orders of magnitude larger than
other humans experienced in their whole
lifetime in terms of the amount of
language they have oh much more
right it's all just about to shoot more
and so from the point of view of um
trying to model human language you could
say well actually these huge language
models just
are not
realistic there's no they're not going
to be able to tell us something about
human how humans learn language because
no human is going to learn from a
thousand lifetimes of data right
so
you know whether we want to learn
you know learn
models using that size of corpus that
really depends on what your research
goals are and for me i'm not interested
in training these super massive language
models because that is not going to tell
me something about human language
learning well so maybe since we talked
about grounding i guess we can we can go
ahead and jump into that and so
just let me try and set this up and you
can tell me where if anywhere i go wrong
for our listeners here which is
so on the one hand you have this corpus
of text and you and you do the
distributional learning to learn what
you can from that that corpus of text as
we just discussed that's not all there
is
you know to to learning the meaning of
those those words so for example as a
human being
uh you know you learn by somebody saying
ball and they're holding a ball
in front of you and you see it and so
you have all this other sensory data
and your observations about the world
which is in your brain is forming this
you know
more composite model of informational
sources and so in in the study of
linguistics the idea this idea is called
grounding which is let's take the
meaning that we have from distributional
learning but we still have to map that
somehow to things in the real world or
whatnot and that's that's the process of
grounding is that correct
yeah okay yeah and so when i was reading
your thesis about grounding i think one
thing that really struck me about the
way you presented it there
and something i'm not a big fan of
honestly is it was presented as like
very black and white very binary like if
i do if i do some distributional
learning and and that distributional
learning comes up with let's just say
whatever set of vectors concepts
something another and then i want to and
then when i want to ground them i want
to map that to
say real world entities it was presented
in this way that every single
distributional concept 100 has to map to
something in the real world and i don't
get why like why can't i have a partial
mapping why can't i have
ninety percent of my distributional
concepts mapped to the real world
physical entities whatever and then 10
map purely to linguistic concepts
themselves like why does it have to be
every single distributional feature has
to map to a physical one i guess the
question would then then be what what is
in that ten percent you know if it's
something like a syntactic property you
know it's just telling you about
um
you know how the word should combine
with other words in terms of you know
word order or something like that then
i would say that's something you could
learn from the
from the distributional data which isn't
going to be grounded right that's not a
semantic property if you have something
like word order
but i think all of the semantics should
somehow be grounded now it might be in
quite an indirect way i'm not saying
that every everything in the semantics
needs to be grounded as in you can
directly point to a real world feature
and say you know that is the
exact feature because obviously that
we've got abstract concepts
how do we graph like this conversation
for example
right i mean we're still we're
communicating with that with each other
right and we're not actually pointing to
physical things and having this
conversation
um and i think there are some big
questions about what it means to ground
an abstract concept
but i think that needs to be something
which we have a more positive answer for
rather than just saying oh we have some
distributional features which are not
directly grounded
i think we should have some kind of
explanation or some theory of how we can
represent abstract concepts in a way
that ultimately does connect to the real
world because you know we are
we humans are entities in the real world
we somehow learn all of our concepts
with the real world how do we build up
from you know more concrete concepts and
eventually get some more abstract
concepts i think that's a that's a
difficult question i'm not saying but
the answer to that but i think that's
something we should try to do an aim to
do yeah i was just thinking that it
seems quite related to the um the
binding problem in ai when we spoke to
jeff hawkins he said that um because all
of the cortical cells deal with complete
objects that was how it solved the
binding problem rather than having to
figure out how all of these low-level
primitives uh linked to abstract
categories but walid on chat just said
that you you think it's more related to
embodiment
but i agree with the sorry uh guy i
agree with guy whenever we we talk about
grounding and embodiment and and it has
to be connected to physical sensory
input we we forget a huge part of our
linguistic communication which is
abstract concepts i mean how how do you
how do you embody uh or ground
friendship or
or the over the notion of leadership we
know what a leader is but uh
do you sense it do you observe it so
that that's a huge question that
it has to do with emergence probably
what the guy was talking about is how do
we yeah i think he's connected to that
yeah right
how do we from the primitive physical
concepts how do how do abstract concepts
emerge metaphorical mappings or whatever
there is in language we don't know
right but i think what worried me in in
you know some parts of your thesis was
that
um for example if a method
like one
let's say one traditional way of
grounding was or to try and link
distributional learning with with
sensory learning was i do my
distributional learning i get a set of
you know
vector values concepts whatever and then
i do sensory learning you know whether
it's
image recognition who cares and then i
try to find correlations between those
those vectors if you will yeah and it
said in there well you know we have no
guarantee that every single one of our
elements of the distributional
vector will correlate with you know
with um some sensory thing and i don't
think that should be a big concern
because
i mean in point of fact every single one
of them will probably have a non-zero
correlation it may be epsilon like it
may have a correlation of 0.0001
but i think that that's okay like it's
okay to have partial
partial grounding because look you know
and you're kind of got some bayesian
concepts in your in your thesis too and
if you're a bayesian you don't worry
about that because down the road you may
get some additional data which you can
then add into your analysis and you may
get stronger
stronger correlations with that new data
and those those other things so it's all
provisional it's all fractional it's all
partial like why are we worried about
methods if they don't give
absolute you know
correlations for every single element
with a particular data set
okay so i think that's the case two
two things i would say to that one is
that
if we're just hoping that by having more
data then we're eventually going to be
able to correlate it but it's just oh
it's just a bayesian problem we haven't
we haven't got enough data to infer
those extra dimensions of meaning i
think that's
very optimistic that we will eventually
be able to find that grounding
correlation being an optimist tim did
you hear that like we need to i need to
mark this down
to the listeners i'm an optimist i mean
i think it's good that you're playing
devil's advocate i think that's it's a
good question to ask but and then the
but the other thing i think is that
saying that oh we you know we
could be happy not to have everything
being correlated i think is
in some sense some sense giving up on
trying to have a full theory of what it
actually means to construct these
abstract concepts right and i think
a full theory of semantics should be
able to explain
how abstract concepts connect to
concrete concepts and it's not like
there's a you know a clear distinction
there's gonna be all kinds of things in
between
so if we talk about the example of
friendship right we could you might be
able to observe you know people
interacting with each other
um and then but then you have to you
know think about actually not just the
interaction as it is but also what are
the intentions behind that interaction
you know what's the you know the
person's theory of mind and so on it's
kind of a lot of steps you have to go
through to go from observing
to people interacting with each other to
inferring something like oh there's some
concept of friendship which is useful
for understanding or somehow
generalizing over the different kinds of
human interactions that i observe right
so that whole process of
abstraction i think is going to be quite
complicated but it's something that i
think we should try to be able to model
yep yeah so so let me just quickly wrap
up there and say fair enough i i agree
with that i think um
i just wouldn't want to abandon
techniques just because they're
necessarily partial
while we're while we're still working on
a better theory because we may close the
door to very useful techniques as was my
worry there so i think in terms of um
you know is it a partial technique so i
cited the also in my thesis um this
contrast that alexander collard um
points out between bottom-up and
top-down approaches in in semantics
which is also came up in his his
co-authored paper with emily bender the
the octopus paper i think we both refer
to as the other thought experiment they
have in there
where if you have a you know bottom-up
approach to to
you know modeling language you say okay
we have this model that can do something
and then we can add something to it we
can add something to it hopefully get
more and more and more of um
different phenomena covered by the model
and i think that's the kind of
um you know the prototypical approach
that you see in in nlp is okay here's my
model now what can i add to it but the
opposite approach or the near the
top-down approach is to say
what is language what am i trying to
model now how can i get a theory that
will get me to that end goal right right
what what's the linguistic phenomena i'm
trying to explain
and
which brings me to the question i i love
where this is going because uh it when
you said nlp we mean nlp as it's done
now because it's it wasn't always the
case oh yeah wait wait wait we used to
study linguistic phenomena and try to
explain them not not bottom-up but uh
and some and some of us still do but
here's my question i think the missing
elephant in the room here is
is all of language learned or is there
some innate part that because because
it's related to bottom up and top down
because yeah if if you look at the work
of george lakoff and his metaphorical
mappings and language how we built all
this abstract space and language which
is all map metaphorical maps from
physical stuff
that whole thing is based on templates
that
i i can't see that they are learned no
matter how many how how much corpora you
process
we're not going to learn that the
contained in relationship is a
transitive relationship that's not
learned do you see some innate part to
language that
it's just not learnable bottom-up it's
there's some innate structure that we
come
equipped with it's it's i mean like we
have a visual system in our brain we
have a language module that's chomsky's
hierarchy that language is a biological
organ but without being a chomskin i'm
not a chump skin but
he equates language with vision in other
words it's biological we have a language
module
which is not empty we don't we don't
come in blank slate and we learn
language from bottom up uh children
don't learn everything
i think this is somewhere well i think
this is ultimately an empirical question
right how much is innate and how much is
is learned and i think this is somewhere
where
uh machine learning approaches can
say something interesting scientifically
because if we can say that actually
for a very generic class of algorithms
something is learnable
then we don't need to postulate that
it's innate right we can say actually
this is just a gene general
um a general property which is learnable
from the data
and so for example say with the you know
the famous poverty of the stimulus
argument
did you mention chomsky
um
this is something where actually at the
time that you know the poverty of the
stimulus argument was first proposed
there weren't really good ways to
quantify it sorry can you can you just
introduce that for the for the audience
obviously the stimulus so this is the
argument that
a human child in learning their their
native language or native languages
they don't have enough
information in terms of what they
actually hear or see right their
stimulus
and their stimulus is too poor for them
to actually learn a language and all the
richness and and detail that we observe
in terms of positives and negatives yeah
right so
also the fact that you know the children
generally only observe positive examples
i mean some sometimes they are corrected
but but the idea is yeah but even
actually empirically you find that
children don't respond very well to
negative feedback if you tell a child oh
you can't say it that way
it's actually not a very good way of
teaching a child um maybe even adults as
well you know but anyway that's a
different question
but empirically if we can now test this
right with with large um nlp models and
train it on a human not like amount of
data so not the kinds of you know one
trillion token corporate or something
but you know a human amount of data so
you know
10 million 100 million
tokens that kind of size
and you know no more than that if you
have more than that you're really going
into something which is not realistic
for human language acquisition
um and you can see actually there are
lots of subtle
syntactic effects which are learnable
from that amount of data
without having to postulate some very
strict
innate syntactic mechanisms i think it'd
be interesting to see you know how far
can you push this you know you know
what's the scope of you know possible
phenomena which are learnable or not
learnable with different um
you know with different machine learning
models
but i think this is somewhere where now
we can approach that in an empirical way
and actually quantify you know what is
possible with or without certain
assumptions i i think one an interesting
way to think about this though is um
from an approximation theory point of
view so i know wally often talks about
this pac learnability theorem so i don't
think people are really arguing that any
of this stuff is not learnable it's more
a function of how vast it is so language
is accountably infinite space of
possibilities it's huge
and neural networks are literally
locality sensitive hashing tables
right so there's just a complete
disparity
between the domain of language and the
capacity of your model to learn it would
you agree with that
i feel like people actually often
overstate the importance of language
being infinite because actually you get
really complicated
you know interestingly complicated
phenomena just looking at finite lengths
of sentences i don't think you need to
go to infinity to make these kinds of i
agree i agree it's not i mean the
language we probably use is uh i mean
it's uh
there's a long tale of i mean the
infinity is not something we ever
probably come across yeah but
but but still it's combinatorially uh
yeah i mean i mean you can
just and and this is not just on syntax
i mean if you look at semantics i mean
with three quantifiers in a sentence
you have uh three different scope uh
orderings uh just to just to order the
right quantifiers
i mean
the combinatorics are huge it's forget
infinity yeah six three factorial right
but
but going back to the poverty of the
stimulus argument
although that wasn't the subject at all
but
because you mentioned we're doing
experiments now which is great i mean
large language models are an experiment
to verify with whether chomsky was right
or not do children have
not enough are they impoverished when it
comes to enough stimulus
well
large language models have told us
already that because we're exceeding the
number of things a child hears
actually an adult years in a lifetime
and we can't we can't resolve references
so obviously that's not how language is
learned
i mean
okay
obviously is a strong word but
but right so i would i would say when i
when i said that you know there's um
experiments showing that
certain
phenomena are learnable i feel like
something like a co-reference is a much
harder problem because that does tap
into world knowledge
um in terms of actually if you have to
resolve a pronoun you know what is it
going to refer to so i think the kinds
of experiments
where i think you can show a strong
result in terms of
what's learnable from a corpus is going
to be more towards for example syntactic
things where
you that is much closer to the form but
it's much closer to actually what you
can
directly observe in that kind of data i
think to get more general
um to look at more general questions
like resolving co-reference i think you
do need to bring in world knowledge i do
think i think you do need to have some
kind of grounded model
if you actually want to model how humans
do it
yeah and i think you know wally you and
i sometimes sometimes get into this
because um
what you've been talking about really is
the context of the individual so like is
an individual human being learning
something ver versus is it already
you know given to them encoded in them
whatever you know that's one learning
context i also often look at the
learning context of
life in general evolution in general
species in general and therefore
i consider you know all the encoding
that's in our in our dna was learned by
that larger process right because
because in fact it did it did evolve i
mean so i think um
sometimes this is where it gets a bit
you know confusing but i think it's what
guy just said is almost obviously true
which is that
text alone and i know while you make
this point all the time text alone is
not complete and it isn't just the
missing text problem it's like the
missing a whole bunch of stuff problem
right like you know somebody's holding a
ball in front of me and moving it around
in some complex way to pitch it you know
across home plate and baseball or
something there's almost virtually no
hope that i'm going to ever be able to
quantify quantitatively explain that in
any amount of text like it has to be
almost visually visually observed
when i say it's not all learned
[Music]
look the the whatever is in our genetics
is probably
uh
i mean
the argument on the other side could be
we're trying to simulate
uh millions of years of evolution with
learning so we will get billion billion
yeah right but but even with billions
uh there are things that
and i'm gonna get to something that i i
discovered just yesterday that a guy
wrote which is of interest to me um
the innateness that i talk about is
stuff that we don't learn in the sense
that they are given to us one shot we we
don't have a choice to learn them
because that's the way they are so let
me there's an interesting phenomenon
language and i was pleased to see guy
wrote a paper about that with colleagues
on adjective ordering restrictions it's
an amazing phenomena i'll tell you why
because
it's
not first can you give an example for
the listeners because it is very
interesting so it's very natural for us
to say john bought a beautiful red car
we don't say john bought a red beautiful
car and and the examples are infinite i
mean you can
it's just
it looks awkward if i say it the other
way around and this phenomenon is called
adjective ordering restrictions
and apparently it's universal in other
words it's language agnostic and it's
culture agnostic you know it's it's just
uh
and that that's what got me interested
in it because it told me that problem
should shed some light on the inner
language the cognitive aspect of it
now
it's amazing that i mean because
it's universal it can't be learned
individually or unless um
so there's some innate aspect to
language that is universal and when we
say universal
right there scientifically we're saying
it's not individually learned
it was encoded by evolution into people
so for example if every single microchip
i build interprets integers is big
indian
obviously if i feed it little indian
data like there's going to be there's
going to be a problem but i think what i
think the point you're making though is
that that that
and what you call it again adjective
ordering restrictions right what's
what's really curious about that is
is
is the cognitive kind of kind of uh you
know insights that that gives you so if
you could talk about that it would be
pretty cool so there's an interesting
line of research at the moment
um which is trying to explain
adjective ordering preferences and other
kinds of um ordering phenomenon
um
in terms of
communicative efficiency
now i don't know whether this is going
to go it's bigger than little indian
right
like that
um
so i don't know how far this line of
research is going to go you know is it
going to be able to explain all of the
variation but even if it explains some
of the variation i think it's
interesting if we can explain the fact
that you would have a certain order
because of
because of wanting to put
something earlier in the sentence either
because it's easier to produce or it's
easier for the other person to
understand
that could be of one way that you can
get this kind of phenomenon without it
being
you know directly innate or even
directly learned it's something that you
even if you learnt an unordered language
you might start to produce it in an
ordered way
another way you can try to get this try
to explain this kind of phenomenon
is in terms of
not human evolution but in terms of
language evolution in terms of how
language gets passed on from generation
to generation and it changes a little
bit with each generation
and you can try to model what's a more
stable
language so it might be that the
language ends up changing into a certain
form which is not necessarily a product
of
you know our our genes in terms of our
innate learning but it's a it's a a
result of the combination of that with
the way that we learn language the way
that we learn it and then pass it down
to the next generation but
what if now it's my turn to be a devil's
advocate what if what if there is a an
explanation right
to this phenomena across languages
that is so systematic
right and it has to do with some formal
mechanism then then that would imply
innateness right
i mean for example i'll give you and
i'll send you a paper afterwards it
could be related to some strongly typed
structure ontological structure
underneath
that
says physical always dominates abstract
and so there's a type system that
is consistent with how we do casting in
even programming language it's
consistent with everything we know in
mathematics so suppose that explains it
that would be amazing right that the
language there's a system underneath
which is a formal system
that subconsciously we follow we have no
choice
that's my interest in this problem
because yeah i think it would be very
interesting if we can if we can shed
light on
how human cognition works in terms of
you know if because it could be that you
know all of these things are relevant
that we have you know some of the
ordering preferences come from some deep
cognitive
um
you know some deep cognitive setup in
terms of how we naturally innately
conceptualize
the world some of it could come from
how language gets passed down generation
generation some of it could come from
um trying to be efficient in our
communication and all of these things
are going to play a role and i think
it's going to be an empirical question
of trying to work out you know how where
do we draw the line how can we quantify
the contributions of these different um
yeah these different factors
yeah but it is it is an interesting line
of work and because i know uh probably
tim and i may be fans of a lot of the
free energy
you know type arguments that life is
conducting this this optimization and so
things like efficiency and
and uh error correction you know
transfer all that matters right and so
so kind of this this ordering and it
does get down to and then i and i kind
of picked the example randomly but i'm
realizing it's more relevant you know as
we're continuing to talk the big indian
versus little indian and cpu
architecture has real world uh implement
implications right in terms of
you know error correction and
specificity efficiency transfer etc so i
mean error correction is actually
something which
um people have applied to explain
um
for example word order preferences or
case marking things like that where
if you hear someone
under noise
then ideally you want the language still
to be you know the message still to be
understandable
even if you have some amount of noise so
robustness to noise is one argument that
you might prefer
a language to have some structure over
another structure right isn't it
remarkable
we're talking about linguistics now but
it it that there are analogies to
cognitive science and we find even
though we're talking to a variety of
different people we're always running
into the same ideas like you know logic
for example and
epistemology and and keith was saying
before the show apparently there are
foundationalists who talk about
axiomatic knowledge and and there's
coherentists who think that it's all
about the connections and the structure
and there are ideas about epi phenomena
or strong emergence or reduction i
definitely think that
you do get these these interesting
connections between you know cognitive
science machine learning linguistics and
i think that's you know why i'm so
interested in the field is because you
have these connections between so many
different areas well i mean do you agree
with chomsky that um language is a
system of thought for example
people are always afraid to give an
opinion of chomsky either way yeah
right
avoiding coming off mute to respond to
these yeah
chomsky has a very complicated legacy i
think
um
and he changed his mind a few times
actually but yeah yeah yeah
it makes it more difficult
um
i would say that
um
you know language is definitely
connected to
deeply connected to thought but it's not
the same as thought
and there's actually some interesting
experiments where you can do things like
for example when people have tried to
test the superior wall hypothesis so the
idea that language influences thought
um and this is one of these
controversial ideas because if you state
it very strongly it's obviously false
and if you state it very weakly then
it's obviously free
so i think the interesting thing is can
we state it in a way which is
not trivial
but still something interesting right
right yeah um and there are these
interesting experiments where you can
get people to try to do some tasks and
you can try to distract them in some way
and you can find that if you distract
you know the linguistic system so
they're having to do another task at the
same time that's linguistic then that
inhibits a superwolf effect
um well if you don't do that then you do
see an effect so you get these very
you know consulting
yeah
and so from this kind of experiment you
can see that the way that language
connects to
generate general
cognitive behavior is actually quite
complicated because it's deeply tied to
some aspects of cognition but it's not
that all aspects of cognition are
linguistic yeah this is what i was going
to say i mean we obviously think about
things that are not linguistic in nature
i mean
when i'm playing chess i don't i don't
i'm thinking but i'm not sure i'm
thinking in language but you do agree
that language was the medium of
transmitting thoughts i mean so free
so it's a subset it's not we we think
about many other things not all thought
is linguistic i agree
but linguistic utterances that we
externally transmit
come from thoughts they are an
expression of a thought no i mean that's
jerry porter's language of thought kind
of
which is uh
related to chomsky but it's even
uh stronger in other words language is
just an artifact
it's a coding scheme to encode
externally my thoughts right that that's
it that's not another person with a
complicated legacy i would say yeah
and and actually i'm afraid of
criticizing fodder more than chomsky
he can be
can we can we move on to the topic of
vagueness is that okay i think uh oh
yeah on this topic i'm very happy to
talk about yeah you have some
interesting interesting takes on it so
maybe just give us a
you know a one-minute synopsis
so
vagueness as it's usually
defined is the the problem that
you don't have clear boundaries for
what um
what words denote so for example
something like red
the word red doesn't have a clear cutoff
between red and orange or between red
and purple there's some kind of
area in between where it can be
uncertain
whether a particular color is red
so that's an example of vagueness
um and
so there's previous work so not my own
work that has um
analyzed vagueness in terms of
probabilistic approach to meaning so
saying that actually rather than having
a
clear
true false value for every sentence we
could have a probability of a sentence
being true so if i say this is red there
could be some probability that that's
true
in
more recently i've been working on
vagueness and thinking about it from a
more machine learning point of view and
i think actually if you start to think
about
learning with real data and in
particular learning with high
dimensional data
because high dimensions are really
unintuitive and i think this is
somewhere where actually a machine
learning approach does say something new
and interesting compared to
um classical discussion of vague list
if you have a really high dimensional
space and you're trying to learn a
concept like you know what is red now
even in for colors maybe you can
describe it in a three-dimensional space
but even in a three-dimensional space
it's interesting right you can say
what's the region of this
three-dimensional color space which is
red
you could you know observe a few points
but if you want to generalize say okay
and i've got a new color that i've
observed is this thing red
the the higher the dimensional the
higher the dimensionality of the space
the more difficult it is to actually be
certain about your generalization it's
actually is this thing an instance of
some concept i've learned before
and the real world is high dimensional i
don't think we can really argue against
that so actually when we have to learn
concepts in a high dimensional space
we're bound to get vagueness because
there's just no way that we could
observe enough data to really nail down
a precise concept yeah it's very similar
to the grain of sand you know that you
if you put keep piling up grains
yeah at what point does it become people
or when when do you become bored if you
keep plucking heads well that's an
interesting example right because so
let's just take the heap example um
it's often presented in this way that we
can describe a heap in this
one-dimensional way right a heap is a
number of grains of sand
so it's you know one grain of sand of
heat okay no it's a you know it's a
thousand grains of sand to keep okay
that seems like it could be a heap
but actually if you think about it
a heap isn't a one-dimensional object if
you think about actually we've got these
grains of sand
let's even assume that they're all the
same you know shape and size but how we
configure them in a space is going to
change whether we called it a heap if
you laid them flat on a table that's not
a heap even if it's a million grains of
sand if you lay them flat that's not a
heap
right that's a thing
right
i like the analogy but let's take
something like tall
i mean
yeah tall is
roughly a one-dimensional con i mean
we're talking about even for even we're
talking about heights one dimension
right okay height but what's the what's
the height of a building if you have an
antenna on the building it's not oh that
that okay
now now we're moving from vagueness to
ambiguity
a big elephant is not a big ant no
that's
vagueness i thought
is a is the vagueness of a predicate on
a specific object
but i think height its height itself is
is a concept and i think height if you
try to define height you have to learn
what is height actually height is not
something that's given to us in the real
world it's not a direct because we can't
directly experience height we have to
learn
what height is
if i ask you how tall is a person you
know it's not just what's their you know
vertical dimension if they're lying down
that doesn't make them say oh suddenly
john is very short now because he's
lying down right that's a ridiculous
thing to say so we we have to learn a
concept of height
that means thing in a you know in terms
of what's the height of a person what's
the height of a building actually
is a learned concept
so even height i think is not a
one-dimensional concept i think that
still requires some amount of
generalization and obstruction to what
extent are these um epi phenomena
like um
you know red or let's let's use the
concept of running
so that is an epi phenomenon and it's
something which i don't know whether it
emerges from
our society or it emerges from somewhere
and now it's got this weird thing it's a
bit like the blockchain it seems
immutable i mean you couldn't change
what running means but it's not a
platonic thing is it because running it
means many many different things so it
seems to be something that it's not
given to us by the universe it's
something which which has emerged in in
in humanity but would you consider that
a form of vagueness or is that different
because it can be more distinctly
described you could argue that the
platonic idea of a circle for example is
is very clearly from a precision and
recall point of view it's very clearly
definable what what i mean by circle um
but are you talking about vagueness in
the sense that it's genuinely difficult
um
so
with something like running okay now we
have a i think it's a related issue of
of policy policy which is i think we
have different kinds of senses of
running
right um i think that's a related
problem it's not quite the same thing
because you could have
you could have a word i mean
theoretically like hypothetically you
could have a word that's policimus
between a number of sensors and then you
could ask whether each of those sensors
is vague
um
i think they end up being connected
because if you actually try to
decide well actually what counts is a
sense of a word
right then you have a question of how
how do you delineate the different
senses of a word and they might start to
you know run into each other
um so i think they are connected in the
sense that they are both dealing with a
question of how to generalize they or
what's the borderline or what's the
demarcation point that's what's going on
between yeah right
so
for policemen you have we have what's
the demarcation between you know
different
shades different yeah different clusters
of usages of a word so see if you have
like you know there's a certain cluster
of usages of the word running in terms
of you know physically
you know going out and um running on
your two legs right
well you know animals running on other
numbers of legs and you've got running
errands you know a machine there's
running
we have these different clusters of
usages
and we could you know think about how do
we actually generalize from each of
these
you know these clusters or each even
just single examples there's a discrete
versus continuous thing as well because
with with red it feels very continuous
whereas with an abstract category like
sour grapes for example it might be
possible to define another discrete
situation that could get attached to
that abstract category
why would an abstract situation be more
discrete well so i mean in the case of
running
because of the policyme there are many
completely disjoint situations which can
have the same meaning
but i wouldn't call them completely
disjoint okay why not so i think
you do so if you actually try to you
know sit down and
write you know what's the list of
possible senses for a word and if you
look at you know what lexicographers do
so people who write dictionaries there's
a famous quote by the lexicographer sue
atkins who said i don't believe in word
senses
and you know this is someone who writes
dictionaries right to word senses right
so she writes word senses but she
doesn't approach it as thinking oh there
is some list of sensors that exist i
just need to find it right
it's more what's a useful way of
describing the uses that we have
and there's going to be some borderline
cases of you know is this a separate
sense is it is it a combination of
sensors do we have to make a new sense
is it a pretty existing sense there's
going to be these borderline cases but
if you're writing a dictionary for
someone to read you've got to decide
what's actually useful to tell someone
here are some different
groups of usages of this word which is
something that because many humans got
to read the dictionary we're not writing
it so what you're saying is the when
we're when we're defining how many how
possible a given uh word is
it's an ad hoc decision we say at some
point you know what this shade of
meaning there's no need for it it's
almost like the previous one that's
enough so people that did work
people that did wordnet actually they
had to make these ad hoc decisions like
yeah
these are enough seven meanings are
enough for line we're done that's it
we're trying to make we're trying to be
too picky by having another shade of
meaning so i i agree with that but
there's still a difference between how
many meanings
running has whether it's policimus or
metaphorical meaning like the machine is
running
and
the fact that one sense
not different senses one sense itself is
vague
yeah
i think i think that's what tim was
probably like well the thing is um i
worry for the symbolists because this
vagueness problem is very difficult to
overcome right the ambiguity not so much
right because um i was going to talk
about this though isn't it remarkable
that human communication is not plagued
by ambiguity uh walid points out in many
of his writings that you know human
communication is characterized by the
so-called missing information problem
which is that you don't say everything
that you mean so ambiguity allows humans
to increase the transmission efficiency
of their language by relying on
your knowledge and
extrapolative local processing on the
receiving end you said in your book
chapter with bender that you know a
well-constructed grammar should be
expected to return multiple parsers for
an ambiguous sentence but it's
completely different to vagueness i mean
that's something which could be resolved
because presumably there was one human
thought behind an utterance when you say
something well first i want to object to
something which is i don't know why
i mean maybe it is but um vagueness
shouldn't be hard for symbolists to deal
with any more than than curvature is
hard well because curvature isn't hard
for a mathematician to deal with right
like in a lot of ways
you know straightness versus curvature
is kind of like um
uh
precision versus vagueness tim uh
here's a solution for weakness that was
developed by uh by symbolists like jerry
hobbs so for example if i say tall
it is a vague concept
who's stalling who's short and at what
point is six five tall okay and and
here's one solution that jerry hobbs
there's something called typical element
typical instance right so someone is
tall
if they are if their height because
every va concept has a dimension many
dimensions sometimes like i said let's
let's stick with one dimension for now
guy for for tall
so let's say tall is a one-dimensional
vagueness kind of problem height so
someone is tall if their height
is greater than or equal to the average
height of a typical element so
there are ways to deal with it and it
does a good job i mean someone is uh
you know what i mean someone is bright
if they are smarter than the average iq
person so we say so there's a typicality
there's a typical
they call it in cognitive science
prototypical concepts there's a
prototype
right and if you're you're tall if your
height is higher or equal
so there are ways to deal with it
i don't know if so if i could add if i
could add two things to that so on the
topic of prototypes i think that's one
way that you could
um define a
kind of
in a funny way a prototypical one sense
concept
right would be a prototypical concept
just has you know a core idea which is
the best example of that and then if
you're closer to it it's a better
example of that right a polysemous
concept doesn't have a single prototype
right that's the difference right right
and so you can have a polysimus a
polysimus concept which
you have to describe in some way that's
more complicated than having a prototype
now whether that's
of a small finite number of prototypes
or whether it's something that's
altogether you know more more fuzzy than
that um i think that's an interesting
question
yeah but that's one way we could think
about you know what what does it mean
for something to be pollissimus
yeah i mean from my perspective and
you know i i only maybe a couple months
ago did i was i told i really needed to
research you know vagueness more because
up until that point and i think still
now from my perspective
the
epistemic kind of viewpoint which is
just to embrace probability
kind of resolves all these problems like
i don't i i still haven't seen yet any
good or any convincing for me objection
to just understanding that almost all
knowledge and you know categories etc
are probabilistic i mean sure there are
you know there are exceptions to that
rule and that's fine you know we have we
have certain
mathematical concepts that are quite you
know
uh precise and well-defined but it seems
to me in your thesis you know you've
you've kind of wholesale embraced this
probabilistic viewpoint as well not only
for vagueness but other you know useful
things and what i thought was really
interesting was this this argument about
the dimensionality and we just we just
produced a pretty interesting street
talk episode that went in you know great
depth about the curse of dimensionality
and these inevitable problems that
you're going to run into in high
dimensional use cases where there's just
no way in hell like you're going to have
a non-vague you know boundary somewhere
and so am i correct that that you're
embracing
probability as a solution to this and
you don't you're not aware of any any
real difficulties or are there are there
still remaining
philosophical objections and
difficulties that you believe are not
surmounted
so i would definitely agree that i
fully embraced the probabilistic
approach
i'm not aware of any
serious objections that there that
still remain at that point um i mean
maybe walid has got something to uh to
raise so on the example that he gave up
for example describing tall in terms of
having
you know some reference point that if
you're taller than some you know the
average height say then that counts as
tall
um there is a
a way to express this in a probabilistic
way in terms of
um
bayesian inference of in communication
so if if if we say that okay tall means
taller than some particular reference
height
but that height is not fixed so we have
some kind of distribution exactly for
that
threshold and then the listener
then has to infer well given
what they know about the world and what
the speaker might be trying to say can
they infer what the meaning is right
based on you're just directly observing
that actually that's why tall in in the
middle east is different from tall in
holland or in norway
so no no because because you're doing
because the different priorities
suggested right you you have a
distribution and you're calculating that
real time so it's uh
the two are related
there's a distribution there's a
population that
what does it mean to say a typical
element well you're saying yeah this is
my data this is my uh distribution
that's what a typical
element is right so you know what's
interesting too is that you bring up
this okay the threshold may have a
distribution
right a probabilistic distribution and i
believe this is original to um uh e.t
james you know and who is a big bayesian
and obviously communicator of bayesian
kind of point of view uh and he brought
up or he created rather this idea of
what's called an ap distribution
which is it a probability itself can
also be probabilistic so you can have a
distribution
a probabilistic distribution of of a
probability and it gives us a great
example of you know consider for example
if somebody's flipping a coin okay and
you're asking yourself what's the
probability that it's gonna come up
heads okay and you flip it you know five
times and it comes up heads five times
in a row you still really wouldn't
change your your uh your distribution
that much you would still guess that you
just got unlucky and the coin is
probably still fair just based on all
the strong evidence you have that coins
usually come up half heads half tails on
the other hand consider the proposition
that there's life on mars
okay if we come back and we launch a
satellite or a probe up there and it
lands and it finds something that is
pretty much
unambiguously
you know bacteria you're immediately
going to decide okay there's life on
mars even though both propositions in
the beginning were kind of 50 50. you
know you might be 50 50 on whether
there's life on mars
50 50 as to whether it comes up heads
you're much more certain about the heads
than you are about mars and as soon as
you get some new data you'll you'll
radically change your view
on mars so i think when you fully
embrace kind of probability and this
bayesian perspective
a lot of things in the world make much
more sense and you stop worrying about
like is tall
six feet or or six feet four inches like
i don't know i mean you you get this new
mathematics that lets you handle all
this in a uniform way yeah i think that
example shows the
importance of hierarchical probabilistic
modeling so it's not just we have you
know one
random variable that we are observing
like say whether the coin comes up heads
or tails but there's a
hierarchy of random variables so this
is the coin fair in the first place and
then based on that
um
that value we can then decide what's the
probability of a particular throw coming
up heads or tails
this is interesting because i think
there's a qualitative aspect to this not
a quantitative aspect i mean the
the example of mars
the indication i have is qualitatively
different it's not a quantitative issue
so
i don't know if it's just a question of
probabilities all the way down there's
well the ap distribution gives you a way
of quantifying that quality
qualitative like concept which was
you know it gives you a mathematics that
captures that that difference you know
the person who starts off at the
beginning and says i'm 50 50 on mars and
50 50 on heads but i have very different
beliefs in those two things this can
capture okay so we're we're back to the
belief uh right
but
i don't know how that is related to
vagueness well vagueness would be that
you know if i have if i have a category
or two categories whatever that whether
or not an object is that category is a
probability
it's not a zero or one assessment it's
that you know there's a fifty percent
chance that i'm tall
and and so as guy brought up you know if
somebody had a certain prior context and
they were evaluating oh he said that
john is tall
i wonder how tall he is
you know they would have a probability
distribution on that i i think we're i
don't know if we're missing something
here nobody doubts that there are vague
uncertain un imprecise concepts nobody
ever doubt anybody that even symbolists
don't doubt that i mean tall is a vague
concept no nobody doubts that the issue
is do we have to de-fuzzify at some
point so i'll give you an example
so and they studied this fuzzy logic is
unsound at some point at the highest
level if i say
uh
john likes every famous actress
liz is a famous actress right
at that point john loves liz
by by deduction
regardless of how f of how famous she is
at that point i have to say she's
famous it becomes a binary decision
otherwise you can't make inferences so
the point is not about nobody doubts
vagueness or uncertainty the point is
you need a higher level of reasoning
where you have to collapse the fuzziness
at some point
there's a lot
i disagree so a bayesian would just
continue working with probability
distributions from start to finish they
would never ever put in a threshold or
discretize until it reaches a decision
point so as soon as right okay but
decision theory is kind of a whole
separate you know category right that's
like i've got i've got my knowledge
which is represented by probabilities
now i need to decide an action and i can
only take one action or whatever so
here's an interesting this does come to
an interesting point in terms of how can
we formalize a probabilistic logic right
because actually there are different
ways that it's already done and
there's different there are different
approaches the the difficult thing is
not just when we have a small number of
variables but we want when we want to
have probabilities for logical
propositions
there are different ways that you can
bring in the probabilities
and depending on how you do it it might
look more or less paradoxical in terms
of making inferences like the the
example the wally just gave of
um but if john loves every famous
actress liz is a famous actress or if we
want to do that inference
how do we set up the the probabilistic
logic so that we can actually get an
answer out for that question right
that's that's the trick i mean obviously
you can deduce the john must love liz
how do you make the calculus work so
that you can make that inference right
and what's interesting is actually that
um so one benefit of fuzzy logic
compared to a probabilistic logic is
that combining to doing inferences is
really easy you just do it on a truth
functional level so for example logical
and logical or we just have a fuzzy
logic version of that it's very easy to
push it through with probabilities it
actually gets very tricky because if you
start thinking about the joint
distribution of all the different
logical propositions you could have this
just becomes completely intractable very
very quickly right belief networks tried
to do that but yeah well you know the
only the only problem with probabilistic
graphical models is you have to design
the bloody things
right exactly so the so this is
interesting thing that i found in in in
my work is that if you do want to
set up a probabilistic logic and you
want to scale it up so that you can deal
with you know um
sentences that humans actually use in
practice
you start to get completely intractable
models
no i i do want to just
slightly object to something which is
so first of all
there is only one mathematically sound
generalization of logic and that is
probability theory now as you point out
like it does create these intractable
problems and so all these other fuzzy
logics are hacks okay they're just
their hacks on the one true sound
probability theory to try to come up
with things that are more tractable but
that's why they run into these
consistency problems paradoxes yada yada
so i do want to just set that goal post
which is look we have
the one true mathematical solution to
this and all probability theories
are uh isomorphic you know to the one
that we're familiar with which is
conditional probability theory with the
sum and product rule and probability so
i agree with bounded to zero
i agree with that part
um but the question is still if we want
to if we have a
so just to make it more concrete
if we define a logical language so we
have our all the logical symbols we want
to use in the language the syntactic
rules for combining them so we have our
set of logical propositions
and for each logical proposition we have
a
true or false value
and so now we have to define a joint
distribution
over all combinations of truth values
and so that's the that's the the goal
and the question is can we do that in a
feasible way well so so look so there is
the one true way to do it which is the
sum and products this is this is so but
i did i did just want to make it clear
for the listeners which is now we're
talking about how can we actually
engineer something that we can do in
practice and i'm 100 on board with you
which is that's
it's an attractable problem it's very
difficult people come up with you know
different solutions to it but i just
want to quell the idea that we don't
have a lot you know a consistent
mathematical framework that's not true
we don't have a consistent set of hacked
rules that we can actually compute
right i mean for me for me look nobody
is questioning that probability theory
is a sound mathematical uh framework
okay because it agree because it agrees
no because it agrees with logic it's a
generalization it agrees with set theory
and
all of that i mean and there's an
intersection all these things are
consistent the probability theory is a
valid science nobody's doubting the
issue is not this the issue is can we
use it
to model human type reasoning
with
uh uh without getting into funny stuff
because
people have worked on that right you're
not gonna get into funny stuff but you
may get into things you can't compute so
if you want to say can we use it to
tractably model
then i would say okay i get you that's
difficult to know but this is work so
this is um
somewhere i think there are interesting
things that we get if we try to think
about the tractability
um because if we look at for example
um quantified expressions like
you know every
if you say you know every
mammal has four legs or you know
whatever you want to say
um
because not that one's not true if you
see you know say humans are too lazy
if you have
every you know every x is a y or some x
is a y
trying to do this quantification if we
have a probabilistic logic it becomes
very very expensive right
especially if not only do you have to do
this quantification but if every single
um
x and y you have to consider has a vague
concept behind it so you've got a
probability of everything being an x and
the probability of everything being a y
how do we actually do this
quantification becomes very very
expensive understood yeah so if you then
take
generic sentences so not every x is a y
but something like birds fly
where there's or ducks lay eggs where
there's no over quantifier
now these kinds of sentences have this
weird what seems like a weird paradox in
that you have
on the one hand they seem much harder to
define
in a formal logic like you say every
duck lays eggs
we can say oh we can exactly know how to
compute whether that's true or false if
you just say ducks lay eggs now does
that mean every duck lays eggs or some
ducks like eggs or
um
most ducks lay eggs
and actually if you think about it you
realize well hang on actually male ducks
only eggs
and you know baby ducklings don't only
eggs
so actually it's a minority of ducks
that lay eggs
and yet somehow it's completely natural
to say duck slayers
and so somehow we have this this weird
what seems like a paradox between on the
one hand it's harder to define what it
means
precisely and on on the other
they're much more natural in terms of
children pick up generic sentences much
earlier than
explicit quantifiers adults process
generics much faster than explicit
quantifiers
but this makes sense if you have a
probabilistic logic where they're
actually computationally simpler to
calculate where you don't have to do
this
very expensive
calculation marginalizing out a huge
number of random variables and actually
you could have a much simpler
calculation for a generic sentence
and so this is where it does matter how
you set up
the the logic because we're going away
from a classical logic we're saying that
actually this doesn't correspond to
um a classical quantifier like for all
or there exists
right yeah that's that's probably why
you know it was probably similar
efficiency
considerations that cause the brain to
develop in such a way that it has all
these cognitive biases and you know kind
of errors of reasoning that that happen
you know perhaps
yeah although the question is whether
when you go all the way down to the base
layer that there is actually a solid
semantic foundation or or whether that
fuzziness remains
on on the subject of this i wanted to
talk a little bit about grammar
engineering uh because we've been
talking a lot about you know vectors and
distributional semantics and stuff like
that and i know i'm talking to a
linguist here and you're interested in
in much richer data structures so um
a couple of questions about your long
tail of large-scale grammars which you
spoke about in your recent book chapter
with professor
emily bender last year it was called
computational linguistics and grammar
engineering so you will illustrated the
um the landscape of computational work
in head-driven phrase structure grammars
which is a bit of a mouthful so these
are generative grammars they're used as
indeed they're used as rich data
structures to represent syntactic
language they have a rich type hierarchy
which you thought would make them very
robust over time and you said in the
book chapter that you appreciated the
clear separation of the formalism from
the overarching linguistic theory and
the ability for the formalism to model
what we're going to call long-tail
peripheral phenomena as well as core
phenomena so most implemented grammars
are built with the goal of handling
naturally occurring text which means
they'll be able to handle a wide variety
of linguistic phenomena that are not
always treated in the theoretical
syntactic work so can you give us a
little bit of background
well and and specifically if you
wouldn't mind
so i'm familiar with you know the
context-free grammar whatever that you
might learn like in a cs course can you
just explain what exactly the
relationship to that in a head-driven
phrase structure grammar is yeah so a
head-driven phrase structure grammar
uses a
typed feature structure formalism
and so as you as tim just mentioned the
so the formalism itself is true and
complete so you could in principle write
a grammar which could calculate you know
any computable language okay so it's a
larger it's a larger class than cfgs and
and yes definitely so is it context
sensitive as well or oh it's getting is
it's true and complete and in the the
full formalism is touring
but in practice you're not going to use
the full turing completeness i mean i
think it would be a bad idea
to try to use the full turing
completeness um so this is that
distinction between what's in the
formalism and what is actually in a
particular grammar right if you're
trying to you know model a particular
language
um so the way that the
the formalism is is defined
rather than having
um
so say if you're familiar with the cfg
you have atomic
categories so if you have each node in
the in the tree it's just a single
category and that's a context-free
grammar
that's a kind of context-free grammar
if instead of having a
single atomic category as you have in a
context-free grammar if you have a
structured object so you have a number
of features and each of those features
has a value
and the value is itself another
it could be another structure with its
own features its own values
so
um what you actually have is uh it's a
directed acyclic graph where each node
is has a some type and each edge has a
feature
and so you have this
richer structure to represent each node
in that phrase structure tree
so that's the
the
says head driven phrase structure
grammar so we're still using this phrase
structure
so we can have a tree but then each node
is not just a single
atomic object but it is this um feature
structure
right so each node isn't is in a token
it's a it's a more complex structure
yeah right exactly yeah um and by using
this more complex structure this is
useful even if you you know you don't
have to go to the full touring
completeness to you to see the
usefulness of of this um it's useful for
example if you want to decompose
something
um for example
if you want to look at a verb in terms
of its
um
it's got a tense and a
it has to agree with the
it has to agree with the subject
um in terms of its person and number
um the verb might have a certain number
of objects
so you have all this kind of structure
which you can then specify in a more
independent way rather than just saying
oh we have a
one
um you know
one non-terminal node which is just has
a specific category which has to encode
all the information we can break it up
into these
smaller parts and so even if you have a
if you even if you wanted to describe a
context-free language you could do it
using this more um you know this richer
formalism so that you can have a much
simpler grammar to describe exactly the
same language even though it's a
context-free grammar
interesting
you can describe it in a much more
efficient way and so from a linguistic
from a linguistic point of view you know
you can state generalizations more
easily so for example if anyone's ever
looked at the grammars for programming
languages you know they they sort of
have to introduce all these kind of
hacked intermediate you know tokens
which can then expand into something
that that would kind of be collapsed
into a more efficient way
to represent kind of branching
alternatives rather than kind of
hacking all these intermediate nodes is
it something like that yeah something
like that yeah yeah okay but i mean one
of the things here is we want to have a
rich and structured way to represent
semantic meaning in language and and you
talk about this really interesting long
tail phenomenon of of linguistic
phenomena i suppose so it's very similar
um in neural networks we also have this
long tail and most of the capacity in
the neural network is wasted learning
the kind of the low frequency attributes
which are the things that hardly ever
come up because they're just really
weird but you said that when working
with actual data and large scale
grammars it quickly becomes apparent
just how long this long taylor period
yeah yeah so you gave this really
interesting example um just to bring it
to life you said it is incumbent on you
to speak plainly and you said it was an
example of a low frequency type which
requires an expletive it subject an
obligatory upon prepositional phrase
complement and infinitival verb phrase
complement which establishes a control
relation between the object of on and
the verb phrases missing subject so
that's just one example of this
linguistic template i mean how many are
there how can we reason about this
i mean these these are really there's a
lot of these templates um so i have to
say that this isn't an example that i
came up with myself so this was um
from the english resource grammar um
which has been developed over
many years now the the person who's had
the most um you know the i guess the
the main architect of the grammar is uh
dan flickinger
and so emily bender's worked with him
for
um for many years i so i was the kind of
the new the junior author in this paper
with emily
um but that example
sort of shows the
the the vast diversity in in um what's
called argument structure so how a verb
can combine with its different arguments
and so you might in an introductory
course learn that okay a verb could be
intransitive or transitive or die
transitive
and you have a few examples of these so
then you could write you know
a context-free grammar that has these
different different verbal types
um and this would cover a lot of
examples you know you can get a long way
with um a relatively small number of
different
um
what are called sub categorization
frames so that how it
how how a verb can combine with its
different arguments
um but actually when you look at a big
corpus
and linguists often interested in that
long tail you know they're not they're
not happy to just get oh we know
we've covered 95 percent of the
sentences actually we'd want to cover it
as much as we can
and if you look at this long tail you
find examples like it is incumbent upon
you to speak plainly
um
that actually this has a very specific
requirement in terms of what it combines
with
and so if you want to write a
large-scale grammar and so the english
resource grammar is a very large grammar
there are
i mean i don't know exactly how many
types there are i mean it's a huge
number of types in the grammar to be
able to cover all these different
types of vibe that you observe in
practice okay that's fascinating because
um what i love about this as a computer
scientist is that the deep learning
approach is very much a black box and
this is a very principled way of going
about doing it but you do say though
that you can still apply probabilistic
approaches almost um as as a second pass
so there are many um ambiguous past
trees that might come from such a
grammar and then you you can start to
apply some supervised learning and so on
on that second stage so do you think
that that is the way forward
i think that's
part of the way forward i think
you know in the
in the long term it would be great if we
had a way to induce this kind of grammar
rather than having to sit down and you
know write all the rules by hand
you know the reason that
you know that
this has been done is because it's
really difficult to induce the rules in
a way that's precise enough that
actually it does it where we want it to
there is work on trying to induce
grammars in a you know a more principled
way so not just a
um
you know a large language model but in a
way that actually
we can say very precisely what's the
kind of structure we have in a way that
you have very very clear generalizations
very clear predictions about what is uh
grammatical or ungrammatical and you
might argue okay maybe there are some
cases where we don't want to have a
exactly binary prediction but um
but still to have a
model where we can have this very clear
structure
i think in the long run it would be
great to and there's ongoing work on
trying to induce this kind of thing
so for example taking the grammar as a
starting point
we could say well can we have a model
that
can produce these structures without
having to use exactly the
um the type feature structures that i
mentioned before do we do we have to use
exactly that structure in order to
derive
the semantic structures that the grammar
produces or can we derive them in a
different way so there's there's work
for example on using
hyper ridge replacement grammars which
is a it's a you know a fancy
kind of expanded version of trying to
use um
graphs instead of having
um
rather than working with trees we can
work with graphs
um
and trying to use you know other
approaches that might be able to derive
the same kinds of relations that the
grammar produces
fascinating yeah um because i'm just
reading some notes you actually quoted
there was a paper in 2002 by
tortanova that said on the ambiguity
thing roughly half of the ambiguity and
the redwoods tree bank was lexical and
the other half was was syntactic and
apparently they were showing that
combining the semantic and syntactic
information was useful for reducing the
ambiguity but i i'm just trying to get
my head around just how much of a big
problem this is because there's the
ambiguity problem we were talking
earlier about the um possibly the
combinatorial i don't know whether you'd
prefer to use the word combinatorial or
or infinite blow up of of language but
as i say there's a lot of structure to
it there's a long tail there's so much
structure to it so it there must be a
root out of this
yeah and i think that's
um
somewhere where we kind of have to rely
on computational techniques because it
because it is combinatorial it's just
really difficult to
do this kind of work on with you know
with pen and paper
you just miss so much of the
the possible predictions that the model
would make
but i think it's also interesting you
know when you bring in this you know
when you bring in a machine learning
perspective because if you think about
the structure in terms of how can we
generalize right because this is always
generalizing to you know to new
sentences
so if we have a training data of you
know sentences we've seen and we've got
some pauses for them we want to
generalize to a new sentence so we have
that machine learning problem
and so i think we do have this
interesting connection between
the the learning problem and the the
structure that we want to learn
and and final question so um
there are loads of folks on linkedin now
that are saying they are nlp experts and
they're they're using models which are
which they probably don't stand and
they're trained to do a specific task
very well um
what do what's your what's your view on
that do you think that it's um
it's something that we should be
concerned about i mean i'm not on
linkedin myself
you know firsthand experience of what
people are saying um i mean there's
definitely a huge growth in the field i
think
there is a potential danger in terms of
whether people understand the
in terms of applying it in practice
whether people understand
you know what are the strengths and
weaknesses of these models
because there's definitely huge
improvements that have been made you
know with these large language models i
haven't
you know we haven't talked about them
that much in this i mean little bit
we've talked about them but not that
much in this um
in this conversation um
because you know i've been talking more
about you know how to model human
language use human language acquisition
if we're trying to think about
practical tasks where we don't actually
necessarily need to worry about you know
how
humans do do something with language but
we want to just build a system that can
do something
then i think it's we need to be really
careful about questions which not
necessarily
technical questions like how do we apply
the puggy fix library or you know how do
you train the model but actually
questions about methodology you know how
do you are you certain about what the
model is actually capable of error
analysis
questions of what's the transparency of
the model you know fairness what are the
kinds of predictions the model is going
to make and how is that going to have a
real world impact i think it's good
there's more discussion in the compute
in the community now about questions
like transparency and unfairness
um
but those are questions which are you
know they're not purely technical
questions
i think kate crawford put it very well
but she said that bias is a social issue
first and then technical issues second
um
and
i think the danger is if people are too
confident in what they know
and
aren't aware of the bigger picture
you know in terms of the machine
learning aspect if you know how to apply
the hugging face library and train the
system that can you know get a high
score on whatever task you're doing
that's a little piece in a much bigger
picture of well where did the data come
from what are the you know do you really
understand your data
um what is it what's the system actually
going to be used for after that
what's the impact of that what's the
ways that you could go wrong because you
know every system is going to go wrong
at some point
and these aren't purely technical
questions so i think we do need to be
you know humble enough to recognize when
we do need to
you know talk to people outside of nlp
and actually understand what's the wider
context of that
as you alluded to these are very
difficult questions and in fact there's
a lot of vagueness you know built into
them
built in them as well you know i mean
like what is bias can even be a vague or
very difficult to pull down and define
you know concepts oh it's very difficult
right so i mean which is you know which
is why i think you know we need to be
we need to be careful when if someone
you know self proclaims to be an nlp
expert and then says that they
you know know exactly what the model
does and uh oh it's not biased because
you know i i didn't program it to be
biased
something stupid like that
um
where actually there's a there's a much
bigger picture there that you need to be
aware of yeah i mean this is now you
know straying outside of my own research
because you know my my my core research
is much more on the linguistic side
rather than the the applied side but
no i think as a field we need to be
aware of the bigger picture well i think
to be honest with you um i take a little
bit of a different take which is that i
think these questions are so difficult
and complex they're really a
field of study and a science like on
their own and i'm doubtful that a person
who may legitimately be
an expert in nlp um i'm doubtful that
they actually
that a human being a typical human being
has time to to develop the expertise
necessary to evaluate their their work
in that broader context like i think
what's going to happen in the future
is we're going to go like for example i
don't i don't do my own legal advice i
go to a an attorney when i need legal
advice right and i probably shouldn't
even be doing my own tax accounting i
should probably have a you know an
accountant doing that although turbotax
you know helps a lot i think what we're
going to have is a profession
and tool sets that make it easier for
people to
evaluate the impact of their work or
potential you know pitfalls and maybe
say hey like um you know university can
you please submit this experimental
design for
you know whatever we want to call it you
know ai fx review or something because
because based on this tool like i'm not
sure that there might be you know
problems with this data set and then
they could come back to you now
hopefully this doesn't devolve into some
type of like
you know ultra bureaucratic like can
allow in progress agenda-driven
you know sort of nonsense um but but
stays more as like a
a science and an engineering and you
know in a mathematical and in a in an
objective kind of policy you know method
yeah i think that's the concern that it
might become a form of gatekeeping or
you know there was a cleric and it's a
legitimate concern
yeah yeah exactly but by the same token
i mean no one understands how their
computer works
and um i mean i love kate crawford i'd
love to
get her on on the show to talk about her
book but um
is it reasonable to expect an engineer
to be that much of an expert and then i
i completely agree of keith that that we
should have guard rails and we should
have um operating frameworks around
doing all of this stuff but in tools but
but no one knows how these bloody models
work
yeah yeah it's a big problem
well that gets into the whole uh you
know
conversation around how to make these
things
understandable
and there's a line at which i think in
one of our videos i said something like
it seems a bit strange that we're
building mathematical models to
understand mathematical models you know
we kind of get into this
circular problem where the
understandable ai feature sets are more
difficult to understand not as difficult
to understand as the is the starting
ones you know i know yeah i made a video
on lyman shep with conor one of the data
scientists at work and um yeah it's
almost harder to explain how they work
than the underlying model
um and anyway um guy thank you so much
for coming on the podcast it's been an
absolute honor to have you on
well thank you for your really brilliant
invitation
thank you it was a pleasure i really
enjoyed it
it's an honor to meet you
okay guys chat later thanks